do you think that therefore there's  there's a challenge with with  charismatic leaders surely there is a  great challenge again and typically it's  not a challenge that they have  engendered themselves although sometimes  they have but it's it it's a challenge  that others have imputed to them and  once imputed to them becomes realistic  and real and so you think dr. King is  going to do this for you and do that for  you and do this for you and it lessens  your responsibility to do something for  yourself no one becomes free because  somebody else helped them do it they  became free because they act in their  own regard there may have been other  leadership figures noble figures brave  figures who helped along the way who  pushed who pulled who did all the things  we expect of some leadership figures but  it was the individual who said I'm going  to do this those are the people who make  the real change